hello everyone and welcome to another
incredible game that was played in round
4 or rather in the tie breaks of Round 4
of this year's 3D World Cup it is
pregnant vs Hikaru Nakamura and this is
the second game of their match I'm
pretty sure you've already heard what
happened and you've seen the first game
and most likely the second one but so
many of you are requesting it uh I mean
it's uh I mean it's just a privilege to
watch uh classical chess being played
like this because uh well uh for those
of you who still haven't seen it I don't
want to spoil too much uh but it was
basically like taking a a stroll through
the park uh so we're gonna discuss this
a little bit later but uh Prague won the
first game he already trapped hikaru's
piece on move nine Hikaru blundered
terribly uh probably took advantage of
that he defeated him very nicely and now
Hikaru needs the bonds back in order to
um uh well to force further tie breaks
so let's check it out uh Prague has the
white pieces and he opens with Pawn to
E4 we have Pawn to D6 we have D4 and
pawn to G6 for the modern defense or the
robust defense we have Knight to F3 and
Bishop to G7 with Bishop to C4 uh Prague
wasn't really
stressed out by this modern defense idea
by Hikaru he probably was expecting it
as Hikaru does tend to use it from time
to time when he is in a must-win
situation so probably Prague was
prepared for even that Knight to C6 and
now Pawn to H3 with Knight to F6 and now
Queen to E2 uh Pawn to E5 and now D
captures an E5 and Prague was very happy
going into this position I can only
imagine as he defeated none other than
Magnus Carlsen from this exact same
position in the crypto FDX crypto Cup in
last year but Magnus continued with
Knight captures on E5 here Hikaru
deviates from the Magnus game he plays D
captures on E5 and now there is a game
where C3 was played but here Prague just
castles and it is now already as of move
8 that we have a completely new game now
this is a great position for white but
Hikari is in a must situation so he's
also definitely happy with a completely
new game already on move 8 we have
Castles by Hikaru as well Rook to D1
attacking hikaru's Queen and now Bishop
to D7 with Knight to C3 going for that
the D5 square and queen the C8 unpinning
from the rook and the D file Bishop to
G5 and now Rook the E8 Pro goes Knight
to D5 as all trades favor him it's uh I
mean he already won the first game he
only needs a draw in the second one and
now if this wasn't the must win
situation probably he car would just
capture and then after bishop or Pawn
captures go Knights to A5 the game
continues it's a nice position for both
white and black but as he is in a must
win situation he goes for Knight to H5
uh Queen to D2 now trying to take
advantage of the dark squares
um as the Knight no longer attacks the
Knight and D5 or the pawn on e4 and now
Bishop to E6
uh just uh uh you know getting more uh
well more uh more of a better Square for
the bishop Bishop to B5 by Prague and
now Pawn to F6 with Bishop to H6 and
King to h8 and here Prague trades Bishop
captures with King captures and queen to
C3 now nicely aligning with the queen
with the black king here Bishop back to
D7 and now Rook the D2 proc now ready to
double up on the D file as Hikaru by
playing Bishop to D7 he did put it on a
bit of an awkward Square once this rule
comes to D1 it's gonna put pressure uh
on on the D file so A6 and now Bishop to
A4 wave Pawn to B5 by Hikaru and just
Bishop to B3 so yeah now controlling
this diagonal this diagonal and the
Knight is brilliantly placed here on D5
so you can see uh uh how different of an
approach it is uh from when Magnus lost
his game to Vincent he played a really
really long grueling game in order to
bounce back but Hikaru decided to just
go all out here we have rooked a 7 and
Rook 8 to D1 and now yeah okay you can
just allow the knights to move in your
Bishop to
get under attack so Knights to be it but
he covered defending the bishop but the
game is already lost Prague is
completely winning here and as you
already won the first game this means
that he is now ready to kick out Hikaru
from the World Chess Championship from
the fide World Cup uh so feel free to
pause the video and try to find the move
that uh wins the game for Prague while I
give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting that
The Rook on A7 is undefended and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is Queen to C5 it's not just
because the Rook on A7 is undefended but
because uh you also gain access to the
E7 square and now the problem is how do
you defend here you can defend the Rook
by moving The Rook or by actually
defending the Rook now moving The Rook
looks nice until you see nice to E7
attacking the black queen and now after
Queen to d8 there's this beautiful
Knight to C6 and of course the bishop
cannot capture because the root capture
is Queen and once or uh if captured with
the Knight then you you've removed the
defender of the bishop so just root
capture Sandy seven so Queen has to go
back and now just eliminate the Knight
here and next you eliminate the bishop
and that's it game over so Hikaru had to
go for the other line that is Queen to
B7 but it doesn't help him as Prague
finds this beautiful Ponto G4 which
traps the Knight on H5 it doesn't just
trap the Knight you might be thinking
about what about Knight to F4 uh sure
Knight to F4 you you can just capture it
or you can even play Knight captures on
F6 doesn't really matter because then
Rook captures on D7 uh I mean so many
lines here are winning it's hard to find
the move here even Knight captures on H3
with Chuck can be played uh you're gonna
play King to H2 attack the Knight and
now how do you defend this the bishop
here is saying The Rook is saying also
the Rooks are attacking the bishop the
Knight is hanging this is just dead lost
for that Hikaru so instead after G4 C6
was played in Here Hikaru knew he was
already in not just lost in this game
but also out of the defeated World Cup
he played it very quickly he didn't even
look at the position all that much proc
played Knight to B6 which is also the
strongest move recommended by the engine
putting up a triple attack here on the
bishop on D7 Knight to F4 by Hikaru and
not just Knight captures and D7 we have
font A5 uh not too much you can do here
at Knight captures on B8 Rook captures
and now Queen captures an A7 again so
many winning ideas here you could play
Knight captures and e5f captures Queen
captures attack the king the Knight but
this just ends the game on the spot
uh Queen characters on A7 Rook the D7
check even with a temporary Queen
sacrifice Queen captures Rook captures
with check and now King to each sex
Hikaru is no longer even playing this
game he is merely coming to terms with
this new reality that he's eliminated
from defeated World Cup G5 check by prog
with f captures and Knight captures on
E5 he now Prague is up a full piece but
of course he still has to play very
precise moves because if anyone can come
back from a dead lost position it is
definitely Hikaru and he will try uh
Pawn to G4 we have H captors King to G5
now uh Pawn to F3 just not allowing him
any chance to spawn to H5 we have
characters captures and now Knights to
D3 offering a trade of knights with A4
attacking the bishop and Bishop to F7 by
prog H4 Hikaru does have the past H1 so
it could be a little bit unpleasant but
now King to H2 we have Knights to E2 and
now Bishop to E6 that we have Pawn to B4
by Hikaru Rook the F7 7 and now Knight
the D4 attacking the bishop but F4 with
check King to H6 and Bishop to F5 uh
sorry after F4 check King the H6 Bishop
to F5 and he was in this position on
move 41 that Hikaru Nakamura resigned to
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here uh you are faced with
Checkmate here and if you want to avoid
Checkmate you have to give up one of
your pieces and you really don't want to
do that since you're already down a
piece and after he captures there's just
no more you can play this is covered by
the pawn this is covered by the pawn by
the Rogue by the rook and uh well you're
just gonna get checkmate or whatever you
play you can even allow black to bring a
Queen into the game it's that funny
let's say Knight D5 a capture some B2
almost bringing a queen into the game
Knight G4 check King to H5 Knight F6
checking to H6 and now Rook to H7 will
be checkmates okay almost bringing a
queen to the game
uh but everything absolutely everything
loses here for Hikaru so that's what I
meant uh at the beginning of the video
that it was uh it wasn't the walk in the
park of course beating your car with no
walk in the park but the way a Prague
defeated him in the first game and in
the second game uh he definitely made it
seem like it was a walk in the park so
brilliant stuff by pragnananda going
into the the final 16 of defeated World
Cup 2023 uh we're gonna see how he does
and these are the uh remaining
participants of the Fida World Cup so
let's check it out Magnus Carlsen will
be facing none other than the Slayer of
Champions vasel evanchook who I don't
know for those of you who are maybe new
to Chess at one point during the Doha
Qatar feeder World rapid and Blitz
Championship Evancho actually defeated
Magnus two games in a row so if anyone
can take down Magnus and anyone else for
that matter it is Vaseline will be
facing also uh I mean a brutal brutal
matchup ninja abasova who eliminated
Peter's wheeler will be facing sound
the former World Championship Challenger
also another former World Championship
Challenger Fabiano caruana will be
facing the winner of the fide World Cup
2021 young shisto of Duda who also
eliminated the Magnus Carlsen in the
semi-finals uh the linear Dominguez
Perez will be facing Alexis Arana Arjun
ergasi will be facing news grandelius
and pragnaranda who defeated Hikaru will
be facing ference berkish so those are
the final 16. uh well I mean it's
anyone's guess what will happen but uh
you know what is what is definitely that
will happen is that we will be enjoying
some excellent chess uh so yeah I once
again really hope you guys enjoyed it
very nicely done by all of them I would
like to I would like to thank my wife
beats any wife at chess Angus Cunningham
Peter booth and nagarjuna punggote and
Philip hexdenberg for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the video
World Cup until it finishes yeah so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day